hallo mein name ist luca und ich
reagiere jetzt auf den videos könntest
dich essen ist gut für die gesund
becker
was habt ihr für den intelligent
patienten
[Musik]
wo war da jetzt der sinn erst tritt er
aus einer tür in einen raum herein und
das lied läuft was übersetzt quasi heiß
ich bin schwach und was ist falsch damit
und dann zeigt er seinen laptop das
der rote faden hat hier war komplett
nicht vorhanden
kannst du das auch mein du [ __ ]
warum bin ich in letzter zeit in so
unfassbar vielen von diesen star
zeitschriften könnt ihr mich da
vielleicht nicht mehr drin abdrucken
[Musik]
ich liebe solche einsendungen freunde
das ist so schön der spielleute klavier
und das ist so schön und dass viele
täter wir und ist es so schön
da ist recht das ist eine lampe die ich
hätte da mal ein tipp für dich wie wärs
denn wir nur die lampe einfach mal an
machst
ich glaube das macht
jetzt
hast du reagiert
ich hasse luca reagiert wirklich
ich weiß nicht ob das auf dem bildschirm
gerade ein fifa match war was du da
gerade beendet hat mal war es auf jeden
fall so aus und da einem tisch bzw denen
löcher da zu urteilen war das glaube ich
wirklich vielfach übrigens kommt in zwei
wochen nicht übels krasse fifa korb mit
seppl auf meinem kanal das ultrabook
red
mal alle in die kommentare da blüht wenn
ihr doppelt seit dem video nach zu
urteilen hast du dir bereits mindestens
vier luca pc gekauft und ist ja nicht
vier smileys am start und da ist sogar
einer von unterschrieben bei und ich
weiß dass du in die käppchen geschrieben
hast bei twitter dass du dich gefragt
das was man denn diesen signierten
stickern jetzt genau machen kann was man
da gewinnen kann ich habe ja vor einiger
zeit gesagt dass wenn ihr in eurer pizza
pizza dir gekauft habt ihr einen
unterschriebenen sticker von gehabt dass
wir am besten mal behalten sollte doch
noch nicht irgendwo dran kleben sollte
oder keine ahnung irgendwie war da werde
ich demnächst gehen wir auf instagram
oder vielleicht bei youtube ich weiß es
nicht genau höchstwahrscheinlich bei
youtube ich da die österreichweite habe
werde ich euch genau sagen was sie damit
machen müsst und zwar müsst ihr den
sticker wahrscheinlich einschicken oder
irgendwie so und dann könnt ihr was
gewinnen was dann aber noch sagen werde
nächstes video man wo bin ich hier
gelandet warum bin ich im gefängnis
ok jetzt nochmal auf hochdeutsch
ich bin's horak uno nein bitte nicht
nicht schon wieder
es war so schön mir sind die tränen
gekommen da es sind ja echt so aus als
hätte ich gerade geholt oder wie ihre
als wir haben jetzt durch dieses video
hier fahren das upgrade ins gefängnis
gekommen ist wegen hoher und er komplett
döblitz also die katze hat gerade
irgendwie sonderheften sprung gemacht
und aber das ist also ist ja schön und
gut aber das kratzt am ego fand ich war
eine lache können wir die noch mal in
slow motion bis jetzt mama working girl
geis am 11 12
damals schon eingeblendet werden wir am
11 12 die launischen lukas aber wieder
eine neue kollektion und es wird zum
loblied das ist das zeichen verdoppelt
das war's jetzt die familie meine damen
und herren ich hoffe es hat euch
gefallen ich wollte mal wieder auf so
ein paar kleinen videos von euch
reagieren die immer auf twitter zu
gesendet habe da können wir auch gern
mal folgen wir sind gerade fest growing
instagram account den ich kenne also
wahrscheinlich wachsen kim kardashian
und so mehr aber von den deutschen
glaube ich so viel schon krass also
freunde folgten auf instagram ich heiße
das laser luca genauso wie auch bei snap
chat da
könnt ihr sehen wenn ich
[Musik]
mir ist langweilig war aber aus
herzliche luca das wasser ziehen
das war's jetzt ihr vom video hier
können jetzt hier mal einen kanal
abonnieren oder hier unten mal einen
schock aus checken jetzt findet ihr zwei
andere videos und wenn ihr schon
abonnent seid könnt ihr auch die glocke
klicken dann willkommen die
benachrichtigungen
[Musik]